um
would you like some god hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
monstrum now this is a game that i
haven't played in a while
in fact i kind of forgot that it existed
but i recently saw that monstrum 2
is about to come out and also this game
has had updates ever since i first
played it i didn't know that
so i'm gonna go into it and i'm gonna
see what's up because i've kind of
forgotten i know that you're on a ship
a few precious seconds against certain
monsters plural
i only remember there ever being one
monster and it was a cool looking
monster
don't get me wrong i think i actually
might have beaten this one now now i i
also play dark wood again
the only game that i won't play again
that you guys haven't seen in a while is
um
a game that i've already beaten vanish
i beat it a long time ago
there's no need to ever bring that up
again no
new objective right
who sniffed did i just sniff or whatever
um oh hi
so i do not remember left click to turn
on the torch
interesting use the torch to search the
room i don't remember if this is exactly
what it was
i must wheel the switch items okay good
to know
um hmm
handy handy that this doesn't seem
familiar
so i'm guessing this is new
echoes what did i just get smashables
okay so for distractions probably is
that important
three four i didn't know that i could
throw that
okay well i figured out how to throw
things that's good so
i'm on this ship and there's a monstrum
on the ship as well now what that
monstrum
is going to do to me this question voice
bright
second launch went without incident
again i see no indication that we were
observed
successful capture rate is improving as
i accumulate time oh
time at the controls six specimens this
time all should be viable i guess we can
enjoy our last day in hong kong
we returned to dock at 6am under close
inspection they are rather beautiful i
observed them for over an hour changing
color in the tank before submitting this
report you should see them the risk from
exposure while they are in the tank is
minimal
and it would allow us some face-to-face
time without interference
right no 12 good i don't have any
context for that note so i have no idea
of what you're talking about
can i hide in this oh i definitely can
yay okay well that's good but i don't
even know what i'm running from so why
would i be able to
hide from something
duck tape
brody i checked up on the serial number
and you're right it doesn't exist i was
able to find the sender mr
s kobayashi i wondered why he was
traveling with us it would seem he's
bought a new residence in l.a and
figured he could use
his own boat as free transportation i
guess if you want to know what's inside
you can ask him i like my job too much
good night larry
okay thanks larry no thank no
thank you you hear that
i hear that
so hot i'm roasting i can't turn on my
air conditioning when i'm recording so
it gets it just gets really hot
oh i'm uncomfortable okay
i'm gonna
restore power there are fuse boxes
scattered around here maybe if i find
some fuses i can power them up
my head is killing me what's going on
where am i um i'm on a boat
i thought that would have been obvious
what is this
electrical connection okay good do i put
the fuse box in here
[Music]
chunk
yes wow
good what did i do oh
good what is all this okay
good chekhov and wilson i think
something's gone seriously wrong i
haven't seen another pair in hours
they went to investigate the engine but
no one comes back there's definitely a
fire i can smell them burning
you can smell them burning the people i
don't want to make any noise by banging
the door i heard fred yelling and then
he just cut off
if you wake up and find this i'm making
for the port side balcony to use the
life raft
i'm leaving i know you're sick but we
have to get off this ship if you arrive
in the next hour i'll be waiting
oh yeah i remember distinctly something
about a life raft and then me breaking
my legs upon it right as i was about to
leave maybe i didn't actually beat this
game
maybe i didn't all right oy give me that
back
all right what is this key to helicopter
the helica chopper keys
there's no need for that so if i can get
to the helicochoopie
then i should be able to get no it needs
fuel or something like that it's some
[ __ ]
a ship how the hell did i end up here
there must be a way out of this i better
look around some more
wow look at those waves well this is all
fine and good but what am i doing here
what
i was drinking water okay
i'm assuming that's totally fine okay so
that's a hidey hole
yeah no one would hear that
bro
you have no idea where i just went
oh hey hi i remember you
where were you coming from bruh
bruh bruh don't do that to me
come on what are you doing okay cool
good i didn't want to win anyway
this is different
this is this is different
oh i still have my same notes okay well
that's good i guess
the new note he has no notes stewart we
got a big rat problem on board found a
load of boxes ripped open food eating
and a mess everywhere
i think they're coming in from the vents
but must be huge they've managed to bust
the cover that idiot santos decided to
be brave and dived in to investigate on
his own
anyway we'll need additional food
supplies while we're still docked plus
the biggest bottle of poison you can
find
oh tempo should have the list in rec
forms from this note
or we can have stuffed rats at sea your
call all right cool not my problem
because i don't think rats is going to
be the biggest issue i have
i have a funkalicious feeling
well that's never a good sign i threw it
again
okay gasp for the hella troopy no date
hopefully ellis didn't take too long
running this to you carlson
i want you to check out the engine room
i know who was frying
we've checked all the connections in the
castle tower so it's definitely nothing
on this side
being without power in the pacific isn't
exactly desirable so get to it p.s
alice asked me why i didn't just fax
this to you in a power out
i think the fats finally moved to his
brain
nice one good one captain or whatever
your name is
x7 turlet
heller turlit
a bottler bob otter nice
good stuff this ship's big
oh hi okay what did i just sub
sub battery a submersible battery you
say
who's hiding in these
all right cool so does that mean that
there's a there's a submersible i think
that would be on the very
bottom oh hey
i've also got gas which i'm assuming is
for the uh
[Music]
the you know the you know
that's the fall that i don't want to go
to all right
oh backpack apparently two gas cans
apparently why do i need two gas cans
i i don't know maintenance good is a
glow stick gonna do me it's only one
right
well this is pitiful and useless okay i
guess i'll just keep going
up for now oh wow
wow wow wow okay is there a point to go
to the bridge
hello who died here anybody
good hello
wow cargo ship didn't know there was
what oh
hey why
you wouldn't be coming to see little old
me would you
i'm harmless no way come on you gotta
leave me alone
i'm just lost at sea a harmless little
baby
all right i'm gonna go down to the
submarineable
i'm guessing it would be somewhere down
here maybe in the engine room
maybe it's actually closer to me than i
think it would be okay deck four that's
where i spawned last time
i don't know if this is completely
okay well
whatever was making those noises can go
make them in hell
and i will carry on
that's fine okay i gotta be getting no
i remember something very bad about
these
i remember something very unpleasant
about the cargo
about the cargo holds
hey a bike pump i'm guessing i don't
need two
gasoline canisters i'm pretty sure it's
a bike pump
no it's a pump for the the the thing the
life raft the life raft is gonna need
this
i probably need that and like a chain
and something else i remember there's a
whole bunch of crap that you need to be
able to get
where you need to get i'm just gonna
keep going down
oh um oh yes
oh my god what is that sound
what is that noise am i dead am i gonna
die am i
what frick screw you i don't know
why i'm unsure i don't know this is a
dive there's a bad
place to be i don't know what you're
doing
what do you die oh you're done
[Applause]
all right then i don't know what i did
to anger him so
but i just remember that i don't like
the cargo holds probably running
it's probably the old running thing is
that the gurgle of water that i hear how
did i get all the way up here
oh but there she be okay so
submersible battery yeah it's got to be
right there do i throw it in
nope good thing i didn't throw it all
right sub
a fixed spoken panel power console
replace headlights well that's a lot of
crap that i don't have
how am i supposed to be able to get all
that kinds of crap okay let's just
explore i'm just trying to find a way
back to the midship
oh this is where the hell at chippy
would be yeah
this is where this is okay i don't have
anything for wait maybe the
gasoline i don't know if this should be
really good
wait is it look at wait
[Music]
oh that's handy okay so i don't know if
the gasoline would be for
maybe some mechanism to control the the
the winch
for the raft i'm gonna go back to the
raft i'm going to pump it up
because i know i can do that oh it's
creepy
why wait why does it go wubba wubba
what do i need the radio for what do i
need a radio for that's some blood
that's probably good oh this is um
[Music]
no i forgot about that just had a
horrible flash from the past
why why are you being all creepy
don't do that okay well this is a big
wide open deck
this is a big wide open deck of nothing
how do i get up there
there's got to be a ladder up here
somewhere kitchen
no no breakable
breakable breakable nothing useful
for me
hi no
no okay
here's this
i don't like the girly i really don't
like the gurgley
[Applause]
okay is that the sub i already have
that i have that that's useless to me
why would you just give me another one
of those
what am i gonna slap to go double fast
probably no thank
the you is that
[Applause]
[Music]
what was that was i supposed to know
that that was going to be a thing
was i supposed to know that they were
gonna be shadow monsters on the wall
that were gonna eat my face was i
supposed to understand that before the
fact
because i didn't because i don't because
i definitely didn't know
all right then take three
i remember now this game's kind of hard
game might be a little hard i was
looking through the container manifest
on the night shift and there seems to be
a misprint container 106 lists
telon as its point of origin i've never
seen this cereal before and it doesn't
match any of the other container blocks
on board
i thought you might have a long look
into it brody all right whatever i don't
know what t-lon is but if it's anything
like elon we want to get it off the ship
immediately
all right cool let's do this what are
the odds there's gonna be a monster
right outside
exactly zero no
stop what is that what is that
i don't trust oh i don't trust like that
i'm going
no no no no this is a dead end
that was no point in me coming in here i
don't like you
yeah you look the other way yeah you
look away you don't look at me
oh no okay we're fine we're good this is
great
breakables i'm sure that this has
meaning
sure lighter
lighter right this is a big ass lighter
security that's got to have something
nice ah
so i can power the security room and
then i'll be able to see where the
monsters is and they'd never be able to
sneak up on me
ever eh
i see nothing i see absolutely nothing
this seems to be absolutely pointless
well this was worthless thanks
i'm on a boat okay i got gasoline again
but i don't know what for
i don't know all right how about up
down up
hmm
would you like some what the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god what happened i don't see
anything
i got a lighter i got a lighter i'm
gonna burn your tootsies off
oh oh it uh well it's a demon oh it's a
mind
player great good
good that's fantastic okay
all right well i'm never coming back
here again
oh oh geez how chihuahua
i don't know
[Music]
am i supposed to do something about that
other than run and pee objective updated
uh
sure uh life raft oh should have a
closer look at it i'm
really far from that now you have no
idea what i'm trying to accomplish
why am i using that i got a big bad
feeling about the big bag cargo
is there anything useful in here kobe
beef
sure that's still good okay ah
more gasoline the one thing i definitely
need
yeah what exactly tore its way through
all these by the way
because there these are a lot of very
consistent holes
you think that it would have just been
able to pick its way out and not
randomly go
literally every direction where am i
what am i
wait what is this well this is weird
okay no
go away any mind flares about mind
flares want to flame them
brain what was that okay sub battery is
if that's gonna actually help me
as if i'm even gonna have a chance at
this but i might as well go drop it off
i guess
there you go bud take that
hope you feel better subbie
do i even have this go away i don't want
it god is there anything actually of use
here
am i gonna get anything of use did i get
new one no
can i get anything of use please
something you literally give me anything
i'm begging you for i can't oh why
but there's something cool in there i
need that how am i gonna open that
how does one open this what is the
mystery here do i need like a crowber
uh
well that's fancy what would that be for
welding kit maybe i can cut my way
through the thing
through the door maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe baby
maybe maybe here
yeah all right fine then sure
oh my god
did you just blow up my heart did this
bastard just blow up my heart
one more try this one is for all the
beans where am i now
uh bathroom okay larry i opened
container 106 at the start of my shift
doorway blocked off with a bunch of old
books floor to ceiling i just left it
later when i sent chekov out on patrol
he came back and told me one of the
containers was damaged
container 106. it looks like it [ __ ]
exploded
maybe we should ask some questions yeah
maybe
maybe brody that is your real name
all right i guess here we go again
hello i'm not gonna pick up anything
unless it's actually useful
no well this is a nice area doctor's
report
date 15th february follow-up enable
stephen wilson and check off
at the behest of captain mickelson and
mr kobayashi
both patients are currently sedated due
to pain
both patients showing slow recovery
possibly due to current conditions
no sign of infection and mr kenikov at
present
that will probably scar but also
no sense of infection in mr wilson
either
what will probably scar what did you
just do to him i don't really care i
have no
say in the matter it's not like i care
about mr wilson but
just kind of worried if it's gonna
happen ben i heard her again i was on
the helipads carrying the fuel hold
she came echoing out of the stern i
tried to make out
what she was saying sound like numbers
maybe either way there's something out
there
may ask wilson for his recorder once
he's feeling better okay great a ghost
report no stop doctor support don't do
that okay suddenly i'm finding these
there's a lot of delays in the big boss
kobayashi's on board
some of the guys are wondering why he's
here and what's his big private stash
down on the hold
let explain why the caps are in period
edge too
but the ship starts soon so i better
make this one a quick one for now
so uh stay tuned for more
i have absolutely no idea how to do this
yeah okay it's a freaking vlogger
it's a vlogger in whatever year this was
in hey what's up dudes
hitting you with another vhs vlog
coming at you well i guess it's not a
vlog it's just a log
hot and heavy with the newest habity
haps on this ship
anyway lots of demons blood everywhere
everyone's dying everyone's practically
already dead
um i'm trapped alone
yeah tell my family please subscribe
i got the helicopter keys that's good i
don't know what i'm going to try to go
for i don't even know what i'm going to
be able to get
oof okay there's gas whatever the gas is
for i don't know
go away hi oh there needs to be some
kind of like
spool reel for this to actually winch
ah it's too much work i'm real lazy i
can't even be bothered to
fix my hair right so why would i do that
okay i'm just gonna keep going
okay another room of nothingness
if i could just get a room with
something besides a cup
yeah i get it there's a lot of cups on a
ship
oh my god the first time i ran through
this it couldn't not get me anything
no i have nothing well i have something
but i have nothing practically nothing
all right i'm just gonna climb clump
stim stomp my way across the deck hope
no monsters hear me
that'd be terrible i'll be terrible if
they heard me
please don't hear me okay sweet
i'm practically free cut restraint
cables find fuel pump unlock helicopter
door
okay uh tada
easy peasy fuel
stomper and slap her on one of my twice
it's so dangly
why are you so dangly okay
no really look i don't know
where the fuel where's the where would a
fuel pump be
how did i find a fuel pump do i gotta go
get a fuel pump
all right whatever man oh no
i don't know why i'm just waiting here
until it gets me but i just want to see
it coming
hey hey man
don't kill me i just wanna leave you
alone hey
hey man don't kill me
oh don't kill me i
want to survive hey
man don't kill me
i just want to be left alone
oh no
okay ah
great did that
nailed it okay
sub hey i only need to figure oh that's
what the welder's for
and then i would just need to find
headlights that's practically
nothing
there would be some good in here there
just better be something good in here
that's all i got to say i guess i could
take the fuse out why didn't i think of
that
i could take the fuse out if i was done
right hey it's the spool
it's a chain spool that's exactly what i
needed for an escape route that i wasn't
going for
all right cool hey don't mess with me
i'm more powerful than you could
possibly imagine all right i'm gonna
tramps through the
storage containers looking for anything
else like the items that i need
to survive but what
i've had my fair share of alien fungal
spores
trying to kill me what's down there
radio and i don't know what else weird
boxes of medical supplies it doesn't
matter they
all one-shot me anyway so what's the use
of even trying to heal
more gas cans what is the gas canister
for
what is the gas canister for i don't
know and i don't care it's not gonna
help me survive
so i don't care hello
where am i where am i
where the hell am i
i've never seen this before in my life
hi 911
one one please thank you come rescue me
there are monsters i'm going to die you
better hurry
or uh i'm not gonna be hard to find
because i'll just be a big red
smear on the wall so i am in the engine
room i did deduce that
but is there any particular reason that
i'm here is there something that i could
possibly do to fix the engines is this
what the gasoline is for
no can't be but it does seem like some
place that would have a nice tool
we have secured the specimens in the
cargo hold for transport the manifest
have been doctored the container is
under a shell company's name which
should keep the prying eyes away we do
not expect the crew to be opening up any
containers at any rate the specimens
seem to be coming more active in the
dark so it'd be worth checking
on the tanks every so often in case they
exhibit any unknown behaviors or if the
stress of the transport
has impacted them oh the poor little
babies
oh whoa is the babies oh the sweden
schnookums there's another spool i don't
need another spool
my flashlight no work what did the
battery die is that a thing that can
happen i don't know
i don't know this game all right i don't
know
anyway it's a big ass engineer
whoa oh i was so confused
i was so confused i felt a box dropped
down there i thought tiny box tim came
to save me
i'm dead was it hiding on the wall
lixian was it hiding on the wall
did i just miss it did i not see it i
don't know
that's enough of that okay so monstrum 2
is going to be coming out
soon i don't know when exactly but when
it comes out i will play it i look
forward to seeing where they
develop on the experience it just seems
like they added more monsters to this
and maybe updated the layout in random
generation i don't know
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching it's always fun to get
a blast from the past like this
and uh cool to see that a game from six
years ago is still around
that's pretty cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye